le sauvetage s'annonce long et périlleux
il faudra plusieurs mois en effet pour
sortir les 33 hommes bloqués dans une
mine au Chili le contact a pu être
établie grâce à une sonde envoyée 700 m
sous terre une microcaméra a ensuite pu
capter les images de ces hommes pris au
piège depuis plus de de semaines
maintenant etchard
Binet des larmes de joie après 17 jours
d'angoisse les sauveteur exulte ils
viennent de découvrir à l'extrémité de
cette sonde quelques mots écrits à
l'encre rou
président les
cam auourd'huiur de monous all
bienous nous
sommes pu les sauvurs découvr cette
image
pres le visage d'un homme apparemment en
bonne
santé des 3 murs pour obtenir cette
vidéo ils ont fait descendre à 700 m de
profondeur une microocaméra dans un
conduit d'à peine 60 cm de
diamètre pour les familles qui campaient
aux abords du site dans laattente d'un
signe c'est le
soulagement nous n'avons jamais perdu
espoir je faisais partie des gens qui
les savaient vivant depuis le début pour
autant les 33 hommes ne sont pas tirés
d'affair le puit principal est trop
instable pour les remonter il faudra
creuser un second passage l'opération
pourrait prendre plusieurs mois au fond
de la mine la température dépasse les
35°gr les mineurs seront approvisionnés
depuis la surface et suivi par des
psychologues par téléphone